[Music]
have you guys ever thought what you
would do if you were a woman for a whole
day
yes you have yeah when I was like 7 or 6
or the moment you become aware of like
the differences between genders you know
wow
does it involved at cities in the clip
yeah I'd be like I think I would
probably steer oh I knew that there was
a different genitals down there I was
like well it's not what I have and like
you would just be the mirror would like
you're a woman for the first time yeah
exactly
and understanding whoa you would do
anything else I want to experience
multiple orgasms and not get tired after
sex yeah wait women don't get tired
after sex
not like we do like we need to find a
train I'm like let me start my day hmm I
don't get tired that's why I like I like
I like morning sex too so I'm like I'm
gonna start my day I'm good to go now
and then God do all I need to take the
[ __ ] a coma like I need to go into
the sarcophagus and recharge
I think I'm not fully there but I'm not
fully where he's at either I do get
tired but anyway so I had thought I have
had dreams where I'm a guy and I have
like a wiener and everything are you
playing with it I was peeing oh oh do
you want to know how that feels to me
you know what a stand-up do I want to
know what that feels like to have
something like outside and like what
does it feel like to have you've ever
water your garden P from your vagina for
in real life and it's like that's about
feels like from like my bot like not the
hose in my hand like I want to know what
the hose feels like yes I got it's a
good damn good release yeah when you pee
what is this you're by yourself right
and he we've been holding it this whole
time when you pee do you go oh
you figured one hand on the wall and
you'll feel the relief that guy's in cuz
if I have I really needed a pee right
and then I tell Bob I thought the
feeling is every gender kind of thing
the way he said it was like every time
you pee it's like oh no no if you hold
it yeah and you really needed to go yeah
it's like ah you know I read about a
really high percentage of people have
this thing where you get the post piss
shivers I get that yeah yeah I get those
too but it's not every single time but I
don't know that maybe lose like the the
heat that's in your body right from the
urine I like seeing that baby do that
sometimes I just just like that like
shivery always feeling it's like when
you see a baby you like they're just
like I mean they're they had their
diaper you know and then they just kind
of like oh yeah when they pee or poop
themselves why do you know what a baby's
[ __ ] taking a [ __ ] cuz they'll squat
and don't just [ __ ] and then they stand
back here and they get back up yeah yeah
a little dude
yeah don't literally just [ __ ] like yo
see I said I could go to the corner me
squats down there's little like failing
the neck I'm like heck are you pooping
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
any squatting yeah it's dump lady
alright well this guy here he asked his
hinge date that he asked this question
cuz he got he kind of got tired of
asking the usual like how are you what
you've been up to so he thought it would
be interesting to find out what this
girl's reaction or a response would be
to the question like what would you do
if you were a man for a day so she
responded with what an opportunity spend
four to five minutes getting ready maybe
not even wear a shirt cuz [ __ ] it and
maybe piss whenever and maybe wherever
for the novelty of standing up sounds
like Bert Kreischer so far
that sounds like her imagination of a
dude is burnt Christ yeah
not wear a shirt no comedian that always
performs with no shirt on
oh good dad bought and he's just like
this they have a beard kind of okay uh
and then she says heavily come on to a
load of men's rights activists to make
them uncomfortable definitely like come
on baby I didn't get that I think coming
on to them as I'm like like that because
they're like overly masculine
can you spell C ome and not see um oh
maybe they misspelled it oh maybe Oh
like like go up to a bunch of homophobe
Spacek hit on oh okay okay
the next one definitely can't call them
to keep scratching my ass she doesn't
know what it's like to be a man because
if you do that you're threatened you're
gonna be threatened like with violence
and she that's her idea though she's
trying to like freak him out but because
she's a man she's she feels less
threatened oh I think I think she's
saying it don't like basically because I
got posed that question now she's being
like well I'm gonna show you how [ __ ]
up guys are and this is what we have to
deal with all girls do here's some more
she said keep scratching my balls in
public sit everywhere with my legs
spread wide open and not be judged asked
someone to kick me in the balls so I
know for a fact period pains are worse
do a very she's not trying to get this
data of course you don't know about that
one you don't have period pains getting
chicken we both can say we both will
never know yeah
I got kicked in the balls well the thing
is not all women have bad period pains
but every guy has bad ball pain if you
get kicked in the balls some guys like
it not kung fu masters logs that [ __ ]
go don't [ __ ] Boulder that day Ikes
you know you know you know you eating
chicken balls has got to be the most the
worst way to get keeping the balls
because while we were filming a skid so
we were trying to capture it on camera
but then when you guys when you did get
kicked in the balls there was a
rehearsal and the cameras weren't I know
you weren't even able to capture the
moment happened it was a long time ago
back in the day and she did a Taekwondo
[ __ ] spin kick - and then like and
Joe was just standing like you're facing
away right she came on behind no one
else face to face face my ex yeah oh
yeah then she just came in this she did
a [ __ ] she did one of these - she
didn't want to look oh yeah I've been
doing Taekwondo for so long I got this I
got she do like that she did one of
those like boom right don't worry I got
control and it was perfect follow
through with a boom wow it really it
feels like you're just getting stabbed
and then like in really bad pain and
then you have to th it feels like it
shoots up here shoots away body
yeah it feels like a someone stabs ya
through your ballsack into your heart
three phases of pain like the initial
pain then it goes up and then it goes
back down and you stopped several men
even you fall on the floor oh that's not
bad cuz for period pain okay good week
and like what you're saying at the
stabbing feeling it feels like that but
all over your uterus like your uterus is
being if I had the choice I would always
pick like getting Kings the balls and
having a period yeah that's like someone
you get kicked in the balls
that's a month yeah just once a month
[ __ ] if I knew it was coming oh it's no
rather how that you
no balls once a day every day for a week
once a month oh she's a period yeah yeah
cuz in the period like then you have to
deal with the blood and stuff well I do
the kick the ball trial phase I'll do
the kick the balls because the period is
not just the pain but also the hormonal
[ __ ] where you move so like I'll just
get kicked in the balls cuz it's just
pain but then the period also after that
week you get to rule the world for the
next three weeks you know I mean I get
to have your way with anybody you want
do a very mediocre days of work and get
more praise and money for it
screw multiple people and not feel bad
after or get slut-shamed and the day
celebrating my privilege on a night out
and not think twice about walking home
after but you wish you'd never asked and
she does like some playful emojis but
yeah like that last one about drinking
and then walking home after and being
chill with them I'm like yeah guys are
so lucky that I I don't know I would
have been media blocked her but even
though I agree with her she doesn't want
the date yeah like I just don't want it
I wouldn't want to date someone like
that but I agree with her in what she's
saying but like there's there's ways of
going about that and like talking about
that cuz us guys understand that too you
talk about like maybe a week or two in
when you're an intimate setting having a
conversation is always greener right
because there's a lot of things that we
have to deal with and it's just a little
bit more like for example like you know
like she says that you can you do
mediocre work and you get all this money
but a lot of the dangerous and
disgusting jobs are taken by men that
they don't really talk about in a dress
you know like a lot of the most
dangerous [ __ ] jobs are just it's
just men's have to men have to do it and
it sucks
that's so I've never seen a garbage lady
that's not the more disgusting things
right it's more like well the dangerous
[ __ ] is like deep-sea diving like fish
yeah like yeah and construction and all
these other things like yeah there are
women love you Liz
but yeah a lot of those things are
complicated topics to write because is
that like gender barrier to a lot of
those things so like like
in construction right like getting into
past the gender barrier a lot of times
into these these companies are all men
see what the thing is that they're
painting it as if it's a desirable job
so that's that's what I'm trying to
point out it's like it's not easier or
harder being a men it's just difficult
for people in general that's difficult
both sides yeah but the way that it's
painted is like it's not always greater
yeah right and it's also there's a lot
of poor [ __ ] up like people and shitty
situations in both genders yeah it
definitely like it with whatever you're
born on like if you're comfortable in
that gender and stuff like you should be
happy but understand that the plight of
the other side is they also have one you
know everyone has their own struggles
right like I could psych a look at a
rich pretty girl and say you got it so
[ __ ] good you were born so rich and
so beautiful you got the whole world
hand to you like I wish I was a rich
pretty girl Yeah right and it's the same
thing like blaming like a rich white guy
I was born with all this privilege it's
like there's just winners and losers
like in a game and it sucks people have
their own version of in their lives
yeah we don't know if like coz there's a
stereotype of you're so [ __ ] rich
that no one loves your ass and like your
family really just used you and and like
the game of thrones kind of [ __ ] like
you know you have these royal people and
everyone's like oh it's so awesome to be
a king and and then like when you're a
prince like they're just using your ass
your own family members are just using
you for power and [ __ ] like that
you don't get to experience love and all
the stuff like the common folk do you
know so I don't know man I always think
that it's easy to look at situations and
be like the grass is greener but there's
a lot of truth to the differences and
how women do have it shitty and stuff
too
so I'm not really denying that either it
is we just have to I think humans just
have to [ __ ] and keep working at it
because everyone got it [ __ ] up I just
have to understand the other side more I
think like yeah you can't just be like
because it's obviously people I think
the hard side of the argument is like
well I don't do those things I try to
make girls feel safe and comfortable and
I don't treat them as in our business we
have girls that are getting paid exactly
no more because they're managing all the
guys you know I want
less
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]